okay
hi thank you so much for taking the time
to watch my talk my name is Juan Perdomo
and I'm a graduate student at the
University of California Berkeley uh
today I'll be telling you about some
joint work together with Michael Kim
who's also at Berkeley regarding this
idea of making decisions under outcome
performativity
so the motivating observation behind our
work is that social predictions are
often performative
so social predictions what I mean by
that it predictions about people and
they're performative in the sense that
these predictions don't just forecast
the future but they can actively shape
what data we observe
um and how outcomes will manifest so in
particular consider this problem of
trying to predict whether individual
high school students will graduate
um from high school on time
so these predictions are performative
and can actually impact the outcome that
is being predicted on time graduation
because the predictions are used to
inform School decisions as to which
students will receive an intervention
and are likely to receive attention from
school counselors and such and who can
and can hence impact the likelihood that
individual students will graduate from
high school on time
um so the observation that I'd like to
point out here is that given that
predictions are actively shaping the
data that we observe what should the
goals of prediction even be
um on the one hand we might think that
prediction is really about forecasting a
good predictor should provide an
accurate answer to the question of which
students will graduate from school and
time
on the other hand we might think that
given that predictions are impacting the
outcome that we care about
um maybe we should dispel this idea that
predictions are about forecasting at all
we should think about predictions or
maybe just a the goal of a predictor is
to steer the data distribution towards a
more desirable Target value say find me
a predictor which induces more graduates
um and the thing I'd like to kind of
summarize is that the right objective is
often ambiguous right this ambiguity is
something that's here to stay it's not
it's not clear that it can be resolved a
priori and it's something that's
inherent to these prediction social
prediction problems that have what I
call these performative effects so the
question that we seek to answer in this
paper is what should we do about it
so our contribution is that we design
learning algorithms and solution
Concepts that Embrace this ambiguity in
performative prediction in particular we
find algorithms which achieve this
notion of performative omni prediction
these are simple predictive models that
are optimal for a wide variety of
different contrasting
contradictory objectives and satisfy
this notion of optimality even when
predictions are performative
so we'll spend the rest of the talk kind
of delving into this definition and
providing some background uh and talking
about the different learning algorithms
that achieve this
so before doing that I'd like to pause
to provide a bit of an intellectual
history behind this project
so our work sits at the intersection of
two different
um very exciting recent lines of work so
one is this idea of performative
prediction and performative prediction
isn't a lot of work that I've been
involved with that formalizes this
causal impact of prediction so it's it
it's a way of formalizing this idea that
predictions can actually impact the data
that is being observed and the second
line of work is
um even more recent is that you have
Omni predictors which has roots in the
algorithmic fairness literature and
connections to multi-calibration and
outcome and distinguishability and it's
a really exciting line of work that
provides New Perspectives and tools for
supervised learning
um if you find the ideas in this talk
interesting I hope you'll go and delve
into some of the references that I
listed here that outlines of the major
results in these areas
um so today I'll talk about how
using ideas from these two different
research direct systems we can try to
provide an answer to this notion this
question of how do we address ambiguity
uh of the goals of prediction in
performative settings
so the talk will be structured in three
parts roughly so I'll start by
discussing this idea of outcome
performativity and provide some
background on performative prediction
then I'll provide an overview of the
solution of concept performative Omni
prediction and at the end I'll talk
about algorithms of how do we actually
achieve this solution concept
so starting with the background on
performative prediction start by
discussing what I call the outcome
performativity thesis so like in this
education example that I discussed
previously I want to formalize this idea
that predictions can actively shape data
distributions so an outcome
performativity we imagine the following
data generating process where we sample
features X say student information
student Democratic demographic
information and it's a sample from a
static distribution d
on the basis of these features we then
make a prediction y Prime According to
some decision rule h
uh after having made a prediction we
then observe some future outcome y star
and here for Simplicity I've described
Simplicity I've described as outcome
variable y Stars being a Bernoulli
random variable the thing I'd like to
highlight is that the conditional
distribution of this Bernoulli random
variable is depends on the prediction
itself it depends on y Prime but not
just X so think about P star of X and Y
Prime as a number in zero one
um so throughout the rest of the talk
I'll make use of this shorthand notation
so I'll say that X and Y star are
sampled from the distribution of h d of
H
um a shorthand for this um
data generating procedure and then I'll
say that P star P star is generally
refers to a function from features and
predictions to the unit interval
so this is like the parameter of the
Bernoulli distribution
um so given this setup
so I should mention that outcome
performativity is a special case of
performative prediction so here only the
outcome is being influenced by the
choice of prediction but in general the
decision rule H can impact the joint
distribution over features and outcomes
so in full generality informativity we
allow for the marginal distribution over
X to also change but we're ruling that
out in this case
um so with this in mind I'll talk a
little bit more about the framework and
um so in performative prediction much
like in supervised learning where the
value of a prediction rule is measured
by the expected value of that prediction
rule as measured by some loss function
over a fixed distribution D because
predictions can impact the data
distribution and each decision rule H
can induce a particular a distinct
distribution over pairs X Y in
performative prediction we measure the
value of a prediction rule according to
its performative risk which is the
natural extension so in particular the
performative risk of an incision rule h
on a particular loss function here at
loss is the expected value of this loss
function over the distribution DH that
the decision rule H induces
um analogously we say that additional H
star is performatively optimal if it
minimizes this quantity with regards to
some
set Capital H of decision rules
good
so that's sort of the background and now
we'll move on to discussing this idea of
performative omni prediction and how it
addresses this question of
um the ambiguity uh and the various
goals of prediction and performative
settings
so prior work in performative prediction
had assumed that this at the time of
learning the debate as to what the goals
of prediction had already been resolved
and at a particular loss function had
been chosen
um when we start doing optimization the
issue of curses that specifying a single
correct objective can be very
challenging especially without having
seen how our predictions can impact the
data
if we decide that the goals of
prediction are wrong previously we would
just need to retrain change the loss
function and retrain
and it's not like we can pick just one
loss function that accurately captures
the whole spectrum of possible
objectives right different objectives
say steering towards one objective or
one target or forecasting can have very
different decision rules so the
performatively optimal decision for one
loss
function can be very different from the
performatively optimization rule for a
different loss function
so the solution we think we propose in
this work is to avoid choosing one loss
function at all instead we're going to
learn a single model that given a loss
we can easily modify so that it is
optimal for that loss even if these
predictions are performative
so this notion of one model that's
optimal for many different objectives
that can be tweaked to be opted for many
different objectives is known as Omni
prediction something that was introduced
in the supervised learning World by
gopalan kalai reingold Sharon and leader
at itcs last year
so in particular an omni predictor is a
regression function p in in the
supervised learning case it's a
regression function P which Maps
features x to the unit interval here I'm
thinking about the case where outcomes
are binary and it's defined in terms of
three parameters a set of loss function
out set of loss functions l a set of
decision rules H and an approximation
parameter
and the key property of an omni
predictor is that for every loss
function in L there exists a simple
false function a post-processing of the
loss and the predictor P such that the
post-processing approximately minimizes
the expected loss up to some small
approximation parameter
so the thing I want to highlight in this
definition is that
um this idea of a post-processing is the
key maybe the key innovation of omni
prediction it says that if you give me a
loss I can tweak my predictor p i can
modify it so that it makes predictions
which are approximately optimal for that
loss and because we're in the supervised
learning case here the expectation is
taken with respect to a fixed
distribution d
so in our work we take this definition
we which had been previously proposed
for supervised learning and we extend it
to the more challenging case where the
prediction rule itself can change the
data distribution so now we're thinking
about performative prediction
uh and the definition is very similar
um except that the regression function P
now takes not just a feature X it also
takes a prediction y Prime and again
mapped it to the unit interval
and it is an LH Epsilon performative
omnipredictor again if for every loss
function in the set capital L there
exists a simple function this
post-processing such that the
performative risk of the post-processing
is approximately optimal so it
approximately minimizes the performance
risk with regard to some baseline set of
comparators Capital H
um and here I'm restating the definition
of the performative risk and
highlighting how
um
performativity comes in because the the
decision rule H is impacting this data
distribution right and we're saying that
the Omni predictor
um
is still Optimum even under even if it
changes the data so even in supervised
learning it's not obvious that this this
definition can be even it can be
achieved
um and Global NL has to prove that such
a thing exists by establishing a
connection to multi-calibration
um in our work we show how these
omnipredictors exist in the performative
setting and in fact they're not much
harder to achieve than in the supervised
learning case
so given that this is for a new
definition that many of you I'm guessing
you may not be aware of I'll like to
spend some time kind of contextualizing
it and saying and trying to provide some
background how I think that this
definition
addresses this uh overarching question
of having to deal with many
contradictory objectives in super in
performative prediction and the
distinction between steering and
forecasting so an omni predictor in
short is one predictor that is
simultaneously optimal for a large
number of loss functions and it's
optimal in a per loss function sense
and in the definition the set of losses
capital L there needs to there's no
relationship between these different
losses
these losses can be completely arbitrary
um they can encode things like steering
they can encode forecasting they can
steer towards different targets
different loss of things to your tour
different targets they don't need to be
related in any way so in short they can
encode contradictory goals
um so Omni prediction is really a way of
achieving flexibility it says I'm going
to front load all the learning and sort
of encode all the things I could
possibly learn
um given this menu of different loss
functions that I want to be optimal with
respect to and then at some point later
in the future I can do this
post-processing and have the guarantee
that the post-processing of my Omni
predictor is approximately optimal for
that loss
um so in particular if we learn that uh
performative effects uh shape a data
distribution in a one way and that
changes what we think the goals of
prediction should be we can simply
modify the Omni predictor so that it opt
outputs predictions that are optimal for
a different loss function
we don't need to retrain
so I spent some time saying what
omniproduction is I'd also like to spend
some time saying what Omni prediction is
not it is not a robust optimization
objective it is not solving a min max
problem uh in particular for this if
different loss functions can encode very
contradictory objectives then the
optimal min max solution might be to
just split the difference and we end up
with predictors that don't up don't
output very interesting predictions
so in particular these robust
optimization objectives can be very weak
if losses uh encode very different
objectives
so as I mentioned previously the key
Innovation behind omniprediction is this
idea of a post-processing which I'd like
to spend a little bit of time making
that more concrete uh and to do so I'd
like to talk about maybe the simplest
setting and what about what how and
illustrate how this um
post-processing might look like so in
particular in supervised learning if the
outcome variable Y is a newly random
variable or parameter P of X
um what is the post-processing
so maybe you'd like to pause the video
at this point and take a second to stare
at it
but for something like the squared loss
if I know this function P right so the
post-processing is done on the basis it
knows what the loss function is it also
knows what the parameter P is for the
squared loss the optimal post-processing
is just the identity right that's just
the conditional mu
um an abstracting away from this
particular example the observation I'd
like to make is that in supervised
learning if the regression P function P
star is the truth in the sense that y
star is a Bernoulli random variable with
parameter P star of X for every X then P
star is an omni predictor for every set
of loss functions L and instead of just
intervals H and uh tolerance parameter
Epsilon because this post-processing
where we just compute the pointwise
minimizer of the conditional expectation
it's the pointwise minimizer right so
then it will be optimal no matter
um what the Distribution on X is or what
the set of decision rules in HR
and this same idea holds in performative
prediction
so in particular in performative
prediction we extend this idea of this
post-processing and it works the same
way so given a regression function P
which now takes in a prediction y Prime
and again outputs
a number in 0 1
the post-processing is just this point
wise minimizer and in particular if the
set of predictions y Prime is finite the
argument is just a can be computed by an
immigration right we're just taking the
minimum value of size of Y Prime many
terms and here I've used the shorthand
that what y sampled from p x y Prime
really means that y sample is a
Bernoulli random variable with this
parameter
okay so the first theorem we prove is
that for any set of loss functions L and
decision rules H there always exists a
predictor P that is an LH Epsilon
performative Omni predictor furthermore
the complexity of P depends only on the
complexity of the functions in l and H
and its approximation parameter Epsilon
it's in particular if the loss functions
in L and the decision rules in h can be
computed by circuits of size s then the
complex there's always exists a
how many predictor P of size polynomial
and S and 1 over Epsilon particular the
circuit size the complexity of p is
completely independent of nature so
Nature's regression function P star can
be arbitrarily complicated but our
omniper there always exists a simple
omnipredictor that achieves its
definition
so that's we'll now move on to the third
part of the talk regarding algorithms
and how we actually achieve uh this
definition
so to do this
we leverage an argument put forth by
gopalan who came Ryan golden reader
which is also appearing at this itcs so
I encourage you to go check out their
paper and they establish this very
interesting connection between Omni
prediction and loss minimization and
indistinguishability
uh an outcome and distinguishability
the idea is that if we can build a model
P so a predictor a regression function
that looks like Nature's P star this is
like the truth the true conditional
distribution of outcomes from the
perspective of the set of efficient
tests then P really is as good as P star
for omnipredictory for the sake of omni
prediction so if you remember from a few
slides back I mentioned that if P star
is the truth then P star is a nominee
predictor and by establishing this
connection to indistinguishability uh it
gives us a very concrete way of
achieving Omni prediction right we just
need to achieve this instinguishability
condition
so I'll spend a little bit more time
making that concrete
so in particular the definition that we
propose this idea of performatively
outcome and distinguishable predictors
so performatively outcome
distinguishable is a property of a
predictor P
um
and it's defined in terms of a set
additional rules h and a set of losses l
and an approximation parameter Epsilon
and it says that a predictor p is an LH
Epsilon performatively on outcome
indistinguishable if for every H in the
set Capital H and loss function L the
performative risk in which outcomes are
sampled according to P is a PR is very
is a Epsilon close and absolute distance
um to the performative risk in which
outcomes are sampled according to Nature
up to this parameter Epsilon
so the intuition is that each pair of
loss function and decision rule H
defines a distinguisher or test function
and if we fool all these distinguishers
or test functions then this predictor p
is a nominee predictor
so more formally for any set of losses L
and incision rules h
if a predictor p is an LH Prime Epsilon
formally performatively outcome and
distinguishable then p is a nominee
predictor for the class h and here
there's an H Prime right so we need to
slightly augment the set of decision
rules for which were satisfy distinguish
immunity condition so in particular
where we ask that we're
indistinguishable not just when we
predict according to H but when we
include the post-processings of p as
decision rules
okay so it says our model remains
indistinguishable from nature even if we
act according to it
in terms of the algorithm such
um
so
in terms of the algorithm to achieve
this in distinguishability
um
it
um it leverages arguments put forth in
the multi-calibration and oi literature
and it's this kind of like boosting
iterative
um algorithm so it starts by we start by
initializing some prediction function
from X and Y Prime to the unit interval
arbitrarily and it proceeds in a series
of rounds at each round we try to find a
test function and as I mentioned
previously each test function is defined
in terms of a pair of decisionable H and
loss function L for which our current
model is not indistinguishable from
nature
uh if none exists then we just terminate
because we've by definition satisfied
the indistinguishability condition that
we set out to achieve if not
then we update our predictor p on the
basis of the uh test function H and L
that exhibits a difference
uh and much like these boosting
algorithms the key idea is that this
boosting step makes common progress
progress on some common potential
function so the total number of
iterations is bounded assuming that we
can solve this fine Step
and as I mentioned previously
um the key idea of our work is that we
show that this notion of omni prediction
in this more what looks like a more
complicated setting where predictions
can change the data distribution is in
fact not much harder than Omni
prediction in the supervised learning
case we show that um
that this auditing step of finding a
test function that exhibits some
difference can be reduced to a
supervised learning problem particularly
reduces to cost sensitive classification
so from a computational perspective this
problem achieving performative Omni
prediction is no harder than supervised
learning
so the theorem that we prove regarding
this algorithm is that assuming it makes
two assumptions the first one is
statistical in nature and it says that
we have access to a data set in which
predictions are randomized
um this is necessary this some kind of
exploratory condition is necessary
because we need to know how outcomes
behave under different choices of
prediction so here I'm just stating this
result for a set for a finite set of
predictions so think about y Prime assay
zero or one a set of zero or one and the
second assumption we make is that
decision rules H are learnable so we can
solve things like cost sensitive
classification over the set h
um the guarantee is that this
indistinguishability algorithm that I
stated previously on the previous slide
then is statistically and
computationally efficient it returns a
predictor P which is outperformatively
outcome indistinguishable using only
polynominally many samples and all the
relevant problem parameters and only in
only polynomily many iterations
good so with that I'd like to sort of
um yeah the key takeaway is that
omniprediction and hormone prediction
ends up being not much harder than in
supervised learning
so summing up we started with this
observation that social predictions are
performative and can don't just forecast
the future they can actively shape it
and performativity means that accuracy
is not the only goal there's this
there's this high level distinction
between forecasting and steering and
this inherent ambiguity as to what the
goals of prediction should be
and in this paper or in this work we
provide one way of addressing this
distinction uh by leveraging this
concept of omni prediction and in a
sense Omni prediction provides
flexibility to choose optimal decision
rules from a menu but it doesn't really
tell us which objective to pick
so this problem of discerning which loss
function to choose is something that uh
I think very much remains open and I
hope uh some of you might be inspired to
work on in the future thank you so much
for paying attention
um
and hope to see you atcs